inflation here is proving much more
stubborn than hoped with food prices
still going up and wages now chasing to
catch up to and that means people paying
thousands of pounds more for mortgages
and the government paying billions of
pounds more for our huge debt pile and
all that could also mean a recession on
the way so really cheery morning for us
well we can speak now out to the former
deputy governor of the bank of England's
Charles Bean thank you very much for
being with us
I know I thought of it I feel a bit
guilty to be honest
um actually by how depressing the
situation is but it does feel quite
depressing uh it's certainly a tricky
situation at the moment uh for the the
bank and for the government for that
matter because inflation has been
stubbornly high it's surprised it's very
significantly to the upside in the
latest data
um and if you look at underlying
inflation measures they're even more
concerning pay growth uh which is
running about seven and a half percent
in the private sector is way above
what's consistent with the inflation
Target uh which would need to be around
about three and a half percent now we
know why it's high because people are
trying to catch up for the uh hit uh to
their cost of living
so even though you've got pay growth of
seven half percent it's still not enough
to prevent some fall in real living
standards
um but it has the effect of perpetuating
inflation going forward and because of
the labor market is historically really
still quite tight workers are in a
position to uh to get those higher pay
Awards uh and the bank will just have to
keep on tightening policy until it takes
enough
uh steam out of the economy and
generates enough slack in the economy to
cool inflationary pressures so to keep
squeezing until we get to a recession
effectively well
um how much it will have to squeeze is
an open question
um economists often use uh an analogy of
a policy of it's like an elastic band
around and a brick and you pull it pull
it nothing happens and all of a suddenly
it comes at you uh and they'll want to
avoid overdoing things but I I think it
is very difficult to see
uh an environment where we at least
don't have continued stagnant growth for
quite some time and quite likely we'll
need some modest contraction at least
now
that right so guide me through this
it's pretty clear the government is
focused on bringing inflation down
that's its number one priority but
obviously the flip side of that is
people saying that wages need to be
squeezed mortgage rates will go up that
we could see a fat recession
is that worth it to bring inflation down
well at the end of the day yes I mean
what we know from past episodes of
inflation in this country in other
countries
is the longer you leave it and the more
it gets embedded
uh the uh more nasty it is when you
finally squeeze it out and is that what
we're seeing now because the bank was a
bit slow it's nastier well
I would to a degree defend the bank
because of course the main reason we
have high inflation is because of the
external uh price shocks associated with
war in Ukraine the rising gas prices
Global food prices
uh also supply chain pressures as
economies reopened after the pandemic
but that said I think they were
um a little bit behind the curve and
they certainly persisted too long with
quantitative easing through the tail end
of the pandemic and they should have
been starting to withdraw some of the
extraordinary stimulus so that actually
increased inflation as well well it's
it's potentially added to I wouldn't put
it as the primary cause but it has
helped to explain why the labor market
is quite as tight the other thing that
is worth mentioning is we've lost half a
million workers who've left the labor
force as a result of the pandemic mainly
older workers and that means of course
the economy
hits up against labor shortages earlier
than what otherwise have been the case
as brexit had an impact as well it's a
bit of the story
um it's not the main part of the story
um there's lots of additional facts
there's a minimum wage is another uh uh
part of the story too
um what's clear is that as far as brexit
is concerned some foreign suppliers
European suppliers have felt uh less
inclined to supply the UK market so uh
Food Markets are less competitive they
will otherwise be more expensive
suppliers and so and there are there's
more costs from that still to work
through because we haven't fully imposed
all of the
um controls that are supposed to be in
place now with less than single Market
um I want to talk about mortgage rates
we've obviously got the bank of
England's decision on Thursday likely
another increase in rates just how high
do you think interest rates are likely
to go uh I think it's difficult
and I'm always very wary of doing that
because it depends on the data
what the bank will want to avoid it's
pushing rates up high and then having to
backtrack uh ensure to order because
that would be an indication they've
overdone it
um I think rates will certainly go
higher from where they are reflecting
these uh bad uh inflation and pay and
like Market numbers uh that we've had
over the past month how much higher they
have to go is open uh obviously the
markets
uh are expecting significantly higher
rates not too far short of six percent I
wouldn't rule that out but it's not
necessarily uh baked in by by any means
work to have a vote would you be voting
to increase interest rates oh if I was
still on the committee I would certainly
uh be voting to raise again and it's
worth saying
um that there is another inflation
release next Wednesday ahead of the
policy meeting
normally
data releases uh don't an individual
data release doesn't carry that much
weight but this one might be
particularly significant because it may
if it's a bad one persuade more members
to vote for 50 basis points rather than
25 basis points so it could go up to
plus 50. it could it could but I'm my
expectation my central expectation is
just that they'll rise a a quarter
percentage point but it's not impossible
they may decide to go more particularly
if it's a bad inflation number next week
is there anything the government can do
right now to try and help the situation
um there's not not a lot they can do to
influence the overall macro environment
in a favorable way there may be things
it wants to do uh to alleviate pain on
particular parts of the population poor
households or whatever uh there
obviously have been some calls for
protecting
um those with mortgages I think that's
risky territory to get into because of
course if you do that and reduce the
pressures on those with mortgages
that reduces the extent to which the
economy slows and just means the bank
has to raise interest rates uh even more
um so any government action would have
to be very judicious I think if it
wasn't a weird we're in a weird
situation where the goal is to slow the
economy down it feels kind of
counter-intuitive uh yes but it's but
it's because the economy is essentially
operating at a an unsustainably high
level of activity at the moment because
what the government really wants to do
is get the underlying growth rate up
um and you know that that's the Magic
Bullet faster productivity growth if we
can get more people participating in the
labor market
uh then that would also help because
that would generate some slacks some
extra workers and take some of the uh
the pressure out there and that was the
one glimmer of good news I uh thought
over the past month in the latest labor
market release there was a noticeable
uptick in labor market activity partly
reflecting some older workers coming
back into the labor force I'm going to
leave it there because I feel like if
there's even the smallest Slither of
good news it's quite a nice place to end
after the program that we've had well
hopefully next time you invite me back
it'll be a better uh Outlook should we
try and do that do you think inflation
is going to be coming down then targets
I'm pretty confident that inflation will
come down almost arithmetically it has
to come down from the close to
double-digit levels it is at the moment
the question is how stubbornly it gets
stuck around about five percent okay
thank you very much really interesting
to talk and guide us through some of the
important things that are happening with
you you're welcome thank you